when we look at the next six weeks
there's a bunch of people who say hey q4
that's when bull runs end uh we saw that
happen in 2017. is your thought process
that the bull run ends in q4 or do we
push into 2022 um and kind of see a
continuation of the bull run in the new
year obviously like you know we're gonna
have to see in terms of the activity and
the metrics and the on-chain data and
the derivatives but um i'm not in the
camp that i think uh this thing just you
know putters out in six weeks and then
we go home uh
and and you know we see another 70
drawdown i don't think that at all i
think um in terms of in terms of
adoption we've kind of hit this
threshold uh this you know the secular
level of of adoption at a nation state
level at an individual level at a
corporate level uh institutional level
bitcoin is is much more accepted uh you
know in 2017
you know price had run up from 250 bucks
to
20k in the in what two years and so you
know we were very very overheated and i
don't think we're really at that level
at all we're still you know flirting
with uh you know the 64k all-time highs
we hit earlier um the on-chain metrics
are not overheated and so you know the
longer we chop the longer we consolidate
um you know people may be getting you
know antsy but that's actually really
polished the longer we chop the more
this kind of spring compresses and the
farther we have to run in my opinion so
i think you know a bull market into 2022
is honestly my base case at this point
and then when you look uh forward
there's obviously the bitcoin futures
etf do you have any thoughts yet in
terms of what we've seen so far with the
futures etf i know that uh barry silbert
and the grayscale guys continue to tweet
out every chance they get that uh gbtc
is more closely tracking the price not
performing the futures etf uh with their
trust but any thoughts there just at a
high level um in terms of someone that's
looking to gain exposure to bitcoin it's
better than nothing um if i was if i had
money you know trapped in some sort of
retirement account or uh you know as an
institutional investor i'd honestly be
looking to allocate towards gbtc um at
something like a 10 or 15 percent
discount in that asset value even with a
2 fee um just because that kind of that
rollover month over month with the
futures etf you kind of bleed out
against bitcoin but again it is better
than nothing i think it's good for the
kind of institutional adoption of the
asset class you know it gains uh it
allows for easier exposure and
allocation you know from these big money
funds not the average retail investor
but uh you know the the institutions
with trillions of dollars of capital to
allocate um and so you know i think it's
just the first step i think a spot etf
eventually comes but in the meantime you
know barry and and the guys at grayscale
will be trolling a little bit as as the
competitors you know get declined like
valkyrie just did
and and so the last thing i'll say is uh
give us kind of a heat check on uh your
friends right so uh we've now seen
bitcoin hit multiple all-time highs in
the last couple of weeks do we have more
friends that were not bitcoin um kind of
knowledgeable or interested or invested
in bitcoin starting to hit you up and
ask you about it or are they still kind
of asleep at the wheel and you know
they're not even caring about it i mean
i have definitely seen an increase uh
especially over the summer um you know
i was talking about it a lot in 2020 and
before that and uh you know price runs
up 600 percent and it's obviously very
enticing um and then you know price
draws down a little bit uh and maybe
maybe some people get get a little bit
scared you know when you're buying at 60
and it goes down to 30 but you know i i
preach especially to people that aren't
too in the weeds with financial markets
or investing and just like hey man this
is a savings account and you just want
your your satoshi account your bitcoin
count as high as possible and so you
know passive dca uh is honestly the way
to go for for most market participants
you know just literally just accumulate
savings in the best money ever and i've
definitely seen some sort of sentiment
shift especially as you know uh
inflation is really hitting everybody uh
it's not something that's more of an
idea it's actually like you know hitting
you at the grocery store it's hitting
you uh with rent with you know at the
gas pump and so it's much easier to
explain the bitcoin people say hey uh
you can't print this thing and so uh in
terms of just sentiment around friends
family um you know just people i talk to
about investing into bitcoin uh at scale
it's it's definitely you know i think
the conversation's changed from from
even just you know six months ago and
then before i let you go tell us about
uh the newsletter that you're writing um
i've just dropped the link in the chat
for anyone who wants to get it you you
guys were kind enough to uh uh give a
discounted link so uh maybe just tell us
kind of what you do how long how often
it comes out et cetera i lead off
content uh at the deep dive and so
that's a bitcoin magazine um markets
newsletter we send daily stuff on on
chain analytics bitcoin derivatives and
kind of the macro landscape in terms of
um you know how bitcoin interplays with
all of this um and so you know there is
a free and paid tier we send emails uh
daily uh to paid subscribers but uh we
send out free emails about uh once or
twice uh or you know a few times a month
and so um if you're just kind of looking
for you know more in-depth you know uh
analysis of the bitcoin market uh we we
provide that and we think we do a pretty
good job